So we're sort of looking forward to or at
least I am more so than I was looking forward
to the conventions, to the debates between
Donald Trump and Joe Biden, which are scheduled
starting in the later part of September, I
believe.
We're going to be covering all of them live
for sure.
One of the things that I've said is that if
you are expecting that Joe Biden is going
to implode and he's going to just be unable
to get anything out and and so on and so forth,
you're probably going to be underwhelmed.
And in fact, one of the things that I've been
pointing to were some of the expectations
when the Democratic primary was down to only
Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden.
You had a bunch of people on the right and
even some people on the left, kind of in the
pro Bernie crowd who were saying, Biden, something's
wrong with Biden.
Biden's going to be unable to keep it together.
Biden is going to be unable to put together
a coherent sentence.
And, of course, Joe Biden did fine in order
to get the debate against Bernie Sanders.
Now, it is true that the subject matter, because
it was heavily coronavirus based, probably
helped Biden in in some sense.
But if you were expecting Biden to be unable
to put together a sentence, you certainly
were disappointed.
And I've made the same prediction about the
debates with Donald Trump.
You have people including like Don Junior
and others on the right who are pushing the
Biden dementia narrative, who are claiming
that Joe Biden is barely going to know where
he is in a debate with Donald Trump.
And I just don't think that's going to be
the case now in advance of this.
Donald Trump has now started floating the
idea that maybe the reason Joe Biden was able
to hold it together in his one on one debate
with Bernie Sanders was that Joe Biden was
on some kind of drug, presumably some kind
of stimulant.
Now, what is amazing to me about this is that
this is exactly the speculation about Donald
Trump, the degree of projection from Donald
Trump and Republicans.
If you look at the RNC this week accusing
the Democratic Party and the DNC of everything
which they have been doing this week, accusing
the DNC of merely criticizing Trump during
their convention.
Well, all they've been doing is criticizing
Joe Biden, accusing the DNC of not talking
about policy during their convention.
The Republicans have not talked about any
policy during their convention.
And now, after years of speculation that Donald
Trump, you know, we've identified Upper Trump
and Downer Trump.
Upper Trump sometimes shows up at events sweaty,
speaking in a sort of manic way, dilated pupils
even in front of bright lighting, sniffing,
glitching, et cetera.
And then sometimes it's a downer Trump that
shows up.
And, you know, the sort of casual speculation
is, is it amphetamines when it's up or Trump?
Is it Ben ZOS?
When it's Downar Trump?
Is it some combination of both?
OK, whatever.
Now, Biden Trump says he wants drug tests
before the debates because he believes Joe
Biden may have been on something during his
debate with Bernie Sanders.
Here's the video.
What nobody thought is that he was even going
to win because he had debate performances
were so bad.
You know, frankly, his best performance was
against Bernie.
We're going to call for a drug test, by the
way, because his best performance was against
Bernie.
It wasn't that it was Winston Churchill because
he was it, but he was a normal, boring debate.
You know, nothing amazing happened.
And we are going to call for a drug test because
there's no way you can't do that.
Well, I don't know how he could have been
so incompetent in his debate performances
that all of a sudden be OK against Bernie.
I don't mean he was good or greater.
I just mean he was a normal, boring debate.
It was nothing.
You understand?
He got through it.
Well, frankly, I thought he he was you know,
they were even more or less.
And most people didn't think.
And so they did something.
Just something.
There was no way because I watch his debates
against Carmela.
There's another one that's a beauty.
She's she's.
If you go by the polls, she started high and
she ended low.
That's usually not a good sign, right, as
far as somebody had to pick.
But against Elizabeth Warren.
They ripped her apart.
So there's a few different thoughts here.
First of all, on the facts, should candidates
be drug tested before debates?
I don't really think so.
To be perfectly frank.
Now, I think if you want to step back and
say we need to look at more requirements to
be president of the United States, I think
it's legally difficult.
The one that for me would be a higher priority
than a drug test would be an actual proper
cognitive test and a neuro psyche.
Val.
Val, like Dr. Bandy Lee.
Talk to us about a couple of weeks ago, but
maybe the.
Country would decide.
Presidents shouldn't be using drugs.
And thus presidential candidates should be
tested for drugs.
The idea of a drug test before a debate is
not particularly interesting to me.
But the most interesting part of it is that
it is Trump who many have suspected of abusing,
whether it's amphetamines or some other type
of upper.
And again, it's all speculative.
But the idea that now Trump is saying Biden
should be tested.
What I hear is projection.
The constant projection from Donald Trump
of the last four years has trained me to think
if Trump is pointing to something, if Trump
is raising the idea, if it occurs to Trump
that Biden's performance may have been enhanced
by some kind of stimulant or something else,
it seems implicit that Trump is talking about
stimulants.
I immediately go to is Trump thinking about
that because it applies to him.
And I'm curious to hear what you think about
this.